before this video begins I'm doing
another giveaway with Origin PC check
out the link in the description and
we're giving it away the Origin Chronos
which I use for my TV setup it's amazing
I got 4k resolution support and just
play games it's smooth it's beautiful
it's it's nice and it can do this look
they even attached a meme look at this a
variable mounting technology patented
but can you do this 10 out of 10 meme of
course check it out link in the
description with select systems you can
get a 256 gigabyte SSD other great
offers check out Origin PC comm great
people great computers and moving out
with video may review just kidding it's
just me I didn't get much sleep last
night
and I'm just like can we this video will
be very chill just one video that would
be very chill thank you very much ok
alright ok
feels kind of stupid making a video like
this because who cares what Peter PI has
to say about literature if you follow me
on Twitter I've been posting I've been
reading a lot of books lately and a lot
of people were asking hey do a book
review so here I am it was three people
that asked actually it's really weird I
don't think I've ever read this much in
my entire life
it just sort of happened and I've been
loving it I had a blast this month
reading these books consider fleebus
brave new world Fahrenheit 451 children
of time the Picture of Dorian Gray and
12 rules of life I basically wasn't it's
not a new year's resolution or anything
like that I used to read YouTube sort of
made me completely stop and I've been
really desperate to just do other things
in my spare time and I've been loving it
and I plan to keep keep on reading and
maybe this could inspire you to read as
well or might just be interesting to
hear what I have to say I don't know
probably not shut up first book
consider fleebus or Flemish or parole
you know this is an important writer
because the title of his name is five
times big as the title of the book I
didn't know anything about E&M banks I
know he's from aces Scottish this was
written in nineteen 1987 I don't think
the title or the cover has anything to
do with the book I just knew I wanted to
read a sci-fi I got this idea that I
just want to immerse myself in a
completely different universe and space
seems like a great place to go I've been
really interested in AI lately and I
thought maybe maybe I can discover that
I just searched up classic sci-fi and
this is what came up it's about the main
character whose name is Horsa and he's a
very interesting protagonist
he's a changer as it's called and
whenever I whenever I read a old
literature that is considered a classic
but hasn't been made into any form of
movie adaptation because Hollywood would
literally take anything and make a movie
out of it but they don't I'm always
thinking why why has this not been made
into a movie and well I think it's the
protagonist how do you make a movie
about a character that can change into
other people it was very interesting to
have a character that's sort of Opie in
a sense he can change into other people
not as seeming lessly as x-men or
whatever that blue girl or whatever but
nevertheless he can do it he has teeth
that if he bites you you'll become
paralyzed and if he even just scratches
you and he will have the same effect
he doesn't really use the powers as -
just as a superhero it's more of a way
to as a power struggle this is so
uninteresting I realize sorry but the
main ki just find it interesting that
the main characters like yes it's really
great abilities and that made it really
fun it's basically about horse I who is
I don't I feel bad for not remembering
this but he's with the adaran which is
his space group of people man I'm
explaining this amazing and in their
earnest at war with the culture which is
this
space group of people and horse I said
he wants through some strange turn of
events he wants to retrieve this AI that
had crash-landed on a planet called
chars world that's the story a lot of
things happen in between but if you
write a summary of the plot it can be
extremely short but it is a space opera
in a sense that a lot of cool stuff
happens you know they they fight at a
temple they play this crazy space game
things that it really was necessary for
the plot but it was fun to be part of
the journey and that's what I enjoyed
about it Ian the writer loves the
culture it's very clear while reading
this that he loves describing what the
civil space civilization is what their
morals are what their ideas are and he
spends a lot of time on this and
personally I found it a bit boring after
a while I wanted to know more about
horror set
why is he part of the adaran why does he
want to retrieve the AI so badly what is
his motive as a character what is that
drives him through to to want this so
badly we never really find the answer to
that which I find to be kind of annoying
but it wraps up nicely in the end and
it's overall just a fun space adventure
I think that's really all it is so I
would rate this 3 out of 5 stars it was
alright it was okay
moving on I wanted to read a dystopian
futuristic sci-fi I read 1984 by George
Orwell before and it's one of my
favorite books it was a book that really
left that impact on me I and the meaning
and the story
tied together really gripped me and I
think about it a lot a lot of people
suggested brave new world by Aldous
Huxley which is very similar to 1984 but
they sort of tackled the same issue but
completely different perspectives
basically uh all Jewess describes a
future this was written in 1934 I think
or something like that a long time ago
and I'll do as describes a future horror
scenario human as a society I think the
year was like 2000 hundred and fifty or
something like that we have a society
where we are just perfectly content
there's no problems
there's no diseases people are born out
of labs through the buckle of ski effect
people are born in without a mother or a
father
they're just genetically produced people
are born into hierarchies so you have
the hierarchies and social caste of
alphas being the top guys Beta Gamma
Delta's is that the right order and
everyone is just content where they are
the alphas are happy they're not deltas
and Delta's aren't happy they're not
alphas and if there's ever a problem
for the people in the society they just
take soma they brainwash themselves with
drugs and they just feel better it's
sort of placed on the blissfully
ignorant sort of way of living and this
is how people want to live this is how
people are happy to be then another
character gets introduced who grew up
outside of civilization he's called a
savage he is basically us he is he has
the same ideas and values as we do and
he meets this new world abrade the brave
new world the civilization that is
completely different and the contrast
between the savage and the civilization
was hilarious
I laughed so much while reading it as an
example he tell us the civilization that
he has a mother a mother I love her you
love her it's very funny I'm not even
sure it's supposed to be funny but I I
life that loud a lot of times while
reading it but then the story like I
said it might not seem as bad as in the
beginning but the story turns very grim
and you understand that things are this
is not a way to live this is actually a
horror scenario and the ending left just
like 1984 a very big impact on me
think about this book a lot after
reading it I love this book I think it's
a masterpiece 5 out of 5 it's an
incredible piece of literature I could
not recommend this enough if you like a
dystopian future so you've probably read
it already anyway it's very interesting
as well to compare it to 1984 1984 was
just written by George Orwell described
a future just to oversimplify he
described a future horror scenario as
well where the government doesn't want
you to read books I guess you can say
but all juris describes the same fear
but he describes a future where society
doesn't want to read book we just
rejected it we reject the knowledge
ourselves so it's very interesting to
have to two fears brewed into different
perspectives moving on I don't need to
go on too much so naturally I wanted to
read more dystopian because I read too
and I loved them so a lot of people
suggested Fahrenheit 451 written by
American writer Ray Bradbury
and you see her on the back Ray
Bradbury's gift for storytelling
reshaped our culture and expanded our
world Barack Obama I hated this book
comparing this book to brave new world
it makes this seem so shallow and so
petty I'll try my best to explain why I
didn't like this book because I know a
lot of people love this book and I know
a lot of you probably have read this
book because ironically your teacher
told you to write this book I bet you
that's the case and the irony of that is
that it probably will turn people off
right reading books
because it's not an interesting story
but it carries a very important message
so so teachers want kids to understand
this message about why literature is
important but it's just gonna turn them
off that's how I imagine it anyway I
need to explain what this book is about
sorry it's about Guy Montag who's a
firefighter sorry he's a fireman but he
doesn't extinguish fires get this he
burns books burning books guys burning
books is bad obviously that's an
important message but I just found it
to be told in a very shallow and
uninteresting manner the meaning was the
story and not the story itself which I
found to be kind of annoying I didn't
care about guy the firefighter I didn't
care what happened to him and it just
made it not really interesting I read
that apparently this book was written in
a few days or maybe it was a month and
you can tell I compared his riding style
to Huxley it's this is a joke I felt
like sense it didn't really have a story
I'm just reading Ray Bradbury's ideas
and his fears directly and it just came
across as kind of petty and anti
innovation maybe at the time it was more
reasonable to have the fear that in the
future we're not gonna care about books
anymore that's Ray Bradbury sphere he's
fair that we're gonna listen to the
radio while doing other things and he
makes a good point actually now think
about it about how we want to be
consumed media so quickly now that I did
resonate to and he sort of goes over the
top with it he seems like the kind of
person that will tell you don't spend
too much time in the front of the TV
because your eyes will become squared
and to me that just seemed like against
innovation in the future yes he was
probably right about the how quickly we
want to consume media but people still
read books just because we have
computers and television and radio that
doesn't turn off from anything maybe I
misinterpreted but that's just how I
understood the writer because of that I
can't give this book too high of a
rating I will give it a 2 out of 5 I
don't really understand its price and I
would not recommend this book I would
much rather recommend a book like this
or 1984 next book so I asked might said
what her favorite book was it's the
Picture of Dorian Gray by Oscar Wilde
another fine piece of literature and I
understand exactly why I might say I
love this book it has a meaningful
a meaningful story with sort of horror
elements to it and I think that hits
that's this what might say would be
interested in the story is about Dorian
Gray who gets painted by Bessel this
painter and the third character which
name is Lord Henry it's kind I don't
want to get too much into each character
but basically Henry and it gets really
infatuated by this Picture of Dorian
it's just such a beautiful picture that
he painted that vessel painted and and
Dorian himself really adores his pic
painting everyone loves his painting but
it's between them that that it's been
painted
Doria this is incredible and incredibly
beautiful man he said he's the perfect
perfect B is described as and he's a
he's in a high social caste he's well
regarded he's rich and he has it all
basically he has everything you could
possibly want but he realizes that he's
not gonna have this youth this beautiful
face forever so he sort of wishes that
he could have it forever he wishes that
he could look this young as his picture
and as beautiful as a picture forever
and that becomes his curse because he
doesn't age at all and instead the
picture becomes a reflection of his soul
Lord Henry I would describe as he's
older than Dorian he is he's lived a
fuller life than him and he has
experience and I think he looks at
Dorian sort of as him himself in the
past and he gives
Dorian advice through different things
and maybe I'm describing the plot too
much sorry really I think it's just
interesting Dorian makes a mistake and
here's what I really resonated with this
book he had the choice to either double
down and just treat it as he did it
wasn't his fault I think as anyone can
do when you make a mistake you can
either own up to it or you can confess
that yeah this is my mistake I made a
terrible mistake
Lord Henry I would almost say is his
devil on the shoulder and he tells story
and no you didn't make a mistake at all
what you did was fine and even myself
while hearing Henry's claim I was like
yeah actually he didn't do anything bad
obviously he did but it remained me to
resonate as myself we'd like mistakes I
made especially on YouTube where you
turn it's hard to confess to the world
that you made a mistake it may not seem
like it and I went through that myself
in my head where I'm like well I didn't
really make a mistake it's not really my
fault
and I shouldn't have told up to this but
I'm glad I did because you don't want to
end up like Dorian Gray because
basically since the painting it's a
reflection of his soul the painting
becomes more tainted by this path that
Dorian has been led upon and it's a very
interesting story about vanity about how
one mistake can lead your whole life
astray and it's extremely well written
and I really really really enjoyed this
book I thought it was fantastic and I
totally understand why it's might as his
favorite book I would rate this horror
out of file next up I wanted to read
sci-fi so I read children of time by
Adrian Tchaikovsky this has been bought
by lion gate I think the film studio so
it's probably going to be made into a
film how are they going to make this
into a film I don't know just anyone
know I think this was more what I was
looking for when I in the beginning when
I wanted to read sci-fi I think this is
what I wanted to read this tackles some
really interesting topics like AI time
human evolution
speciesism how we value other species it
was very interesting to describe the
plot without any spoilers I think the
best way I can say it it's humanity's
last hope
is on this and then there's also
humanity's old Empire as it's called
sort of lingering in space and then
there's this planet where humanity wants
to go to but there's there's things on
the planet so there's a power play in
between the planet humanity's last hope
and the old Empire
and you follow each of these
perspectives more or less and it's just
very interesting it really made me look
differently on how we value species I
look at humanity in the future but
overall it was just a fun space
adventure I really enjoyed it I thought
it was it was fun from the beginning to
the end I didn't really like the main
character I guess I didn't I wasn't as
gripped by an S I think a lot of all the
people probably would be it has an
incredibly unexpected character in it
without spoiling it and I don't
understand how they're gonna turn that
into a film maybe I'm making it seem
more interesting in that it is but if
you want to go on a modern space a
sci-fi space thing this is why I'll
never read it write a book this is it
it's very great very good very great
Ellison um I've been talking a lot now
you still here great because I've been
trying to cut it short I don't think
I'll ever read this much in a month
because the last book I read which I
finished last night which is probably
why I'm so tired is 12 rules of life an
antidote to chaos by Jordan the
Petersons you may know about Jordan B
Peterson already he's very popular on
YouTube for being sort of a free thinker
he's sort of a controversial figure head
as well and I think he's gotten a lot
more flak than he deserves
because of it because he's very cut and
dry with his ideas which is why he's
been so embraced by the internet and
disliked by immediate which I can sort
of relate to here have you seen that
interview he did with the channel 4 it's
sort of gone viral it became a meme
almost because the lady that tries to
interview Jordan
try and straw men argue against him she
keeps going oh so you're saying this
right you're just saying that's the way
it is yours anyway on women have some
sort of duty so if you want why you
should dominate but you're saying
basically it doesn't matter it made it
made her goal was to make him look bad
and trash Jordans name in this interview
he completely shut her down and he made
her look
really vicious and really eats spiteful
and it really made me want to read this
book because of it cuz I was like wow
that's really impressive and the Channel
4 News lady if you read the damn book
you would have fallen into that trap he
even discusses straw man arguing and why
that's wrong in in the book ha gotcha
anyway about the book itself at 12 rules
of life I didn't read the title it's a
self health book I don't think I ever
would have read a self-help book it gave
me a lot of new perspectives that I
never thought I wouldn't even have it
was very interesting even reading about
advice that doesn't resonate with me at
all but just to understand other people
Jordan goes very deep in philosophical
thinking and psychological thinking and
he makes his very simple claims right uh
tell the truth for example rule eight
where at least don't lie we know that we
know not to to line and we know the
moral implications of that but he goes
so in depth in a philosophical and and
like I said a psychological way and how
that by telling lies it really twists
your worldview I really resonated with
it that was their only rule where I was
like I don't ever want to lie this is he
really makes a great point here so I
thought that was really interesting
there was a lot of rules I didn't I
didn't need to read at all about racing
kids or like how to deal with the cope
with the failing marriage and that sort
of stuff but you can tell Jordans goal
for this is to help people you can
really appreciate that at least I think
he unfortunately does it in a way that
he goes on a little too long sometimes
sometimes I find it a bit beating the
point to death and some of the analogies
that he made seemed strange at times
they didn't really seem like they fit
hey drawers he draws the comparisons and
analogies from Disney movies to old
biblical stories
and there's a lot of religious analogies
in this book a lot of religious
analogies and I didn't realize until the
very last chapter I was like he's
religious
I thought he grew up in a Christian
household or something like that and and
the reason that he drew a lot of
religious analogies was because to prove
the point that we always knew about this
or maybe this is something that we we've
known for thousands of years through
this biblical text whenever I look at
self-help I can't help but feel a bit
critical like is it what it is is some
sort of cult book or something like that
and finding out that he was religious in
the end and it sort of changed my
perspective on the book I know that's
kind of stupid maybe but he even even
Jordan himself brings it up that the
past can can be changed from the future
and it's not that big of a deal but I
feel like it's probably unfair for me to
say but anytime self-help I'm like this
is just some sort of cult following
it's not it's not at all but it
made me look more critically at the
rules which I think you should do any
time you get advice about how to live
your life so I think that was fine I
didn't I didn't ruin anything for me but
I surprisingly like I said I really
enjoyed this book it was very fun to
read I will definitely take some lessons
from this book absolutely and it also
made me understand other people around
me better that was the book I read in
January I want to keep reading I hope
this was fun to listen to I know I've
been going on a long time 30 minutes
it's probably cut down a bit I had a lot
of fun talking about these books I had a
lot of fun this month having a hobby
that doesn't involve YouTube I used to I
used to read but YouTube just took over
my life hopefully this might inspire you
to read more as well and maybe you'll
pick up one of these next month if you
want to join me
book club I know already which books I'm
gonna read next month not all of them
but I know I want to read Beyond Good
and Evil from Frederick Nietzsche
everyone talks about Nietzsche all the
time I never read anything from him and
Jordan mentioned him a lot so I I knew I
wanted to read this
I'm gonna read live 3.0 by Max tegmark
which is he describes AI and how it how
it may or may not affect us in the
future
he is the Swedish genius I don't know if
he's genius but he the people compared
him to the Swedish Elon Musk and Elon
Musk even praises the book my parents
recommended this as well so I started
already a little bit and it's very
interesting and I want to read what you
guys suggest me leave your let me know
in the comments if there's anything that
you think I might be interested in
living like if you enjoyed I really hope
you did if anything this is just one
video compared to a lot of other where I
go and act like a Dorian so that's it
goodbye bye now squash him
it's my Dory hair up like this whole
time